foreign
[Music]
hello everyone
um my name is John Laurent uh I'm the
the r director at uh pandemic response
labs in NYC
um and I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the testing and sequencing for
SARS code V2 that we've been doing at
the lab and a little bit of the origin
story
um and then a little bit of detail about
what our testing platform looks like
what our sequencing platform looks like
and some of the data that's coming off
of it
um and also before we continue just want
to thank the organizers uh for the
invitation to to speak to you and and
for you all for listening
uh so let's jump into it
um so really uh at its core
um as I'm sure a lot of you understand
the code to uh test principle is pretty
straightforward it's just a PCR uh it is
uh in particular a reverse transcription
TCR and it's technically a qpcr uh
although there is usually no
quantitative measure taken uh during the
test it's just a qualitative detection
or no detection and so really at its
core what what we need to do to test for
cov2 in a specific sample is to take a
swab from a person extract the RNA and
run a PCR on that extracted nucleic acid
to
basically test for for presence of
nucleic acid from the viral genome but
the real question that we wanted to
answer and to help out with at the sort
of height of the pandemic uh this time
roughly this time last year was to
really make this High throughput because
New York City was really at the peak of
of the pandemic
um the city was really hurting there was
a dearth testing
and so we we thought we could meet some
of those needs for testing
um because of some specific
infrastructure we had in the lab
and so the question we asked is how do
we make this process more High
throughput
um and the way that we answer that
really is just by automating and
parallelizing and of course along with
that we had plates with a lot of little
tiny Wells uh just to handle all of
those samples
and so if we expand those two very
simplistic representations of the cove2
test steps into a little uh a little
more granular view of what that involves
we can expand the sample processing part
of that into acquisition of samples
accessioning of samples which is really
just acknowledgment that you've received
that sample and and entered it into your
tracking system in the lab and then
reformatting of those samples into a
format that is more amenable to
processing and automation because they
do come in a large file uh usually and
then on the the sort of testing and PCR
side we take those reformatted samples
we have to isolate the RNA from it or or
the nucleic acid we have to set up the
PCR reaction and then we have to run the
PCR reaction
and so on the right side the PCR side of
this uh and this and the isolation and
PCR setup and PCR we were actually
already doing most of this process in
the lab at NYU where I was prior to my
position at Pro
um and we were doing this for a very
different purpose than any sort of
diagnostic testing but rather for
actually screening very large DNA
assemblies that we were building in the
lab on the megabase scale and so we had
set up a high throughput qpcr platform
for doing those screens and so like I
was saying we had the infrastructure in
place to really help out the
with the testing the lack of testing in
the city at the time
and so
what we really needed to do was adapt
this blue bit
um
that we already had set up in the lab
just so that it was specific to a
coveted diagnostic test rather than a
big DNA assembly screening PCR test
and then the front end we had to figure
all of that out so how do we receive
samples in the tens of thousands how do
we accession them how do we reformat
them so that was the the problem we had
to solve
um and so I'll take you through a little
bit of detail on on how covet testing
works and then what we how we ended up
uh designing this platform
so
uh
just to zoom in a little bit on some
details here
um covid as I said was is just the PCR
really
um and so what you need to do uh to have
a PCR is have primers to amplify your
Target and then in particular it is a
qpcr so it's a quantitative PCR that
uses real-time detection of that
amplification
and it's not it's a it in particular
uses a probe based detection and so
um on the top of this diagram I'm just
showing sort of a generic uh
uh coronavirus genome and the proteins
that are coded on that genome and all
the way over on the right side is what's
called a nucleocapsody gene
um
and this otherwise known as the engine
and this is where the primers are that
we are detecting in our
um in our test and so really what we're
detecting is the presence of the SARS
Kobe 2 nuclear capsid Gene and these
primers are actually originally designed
by the CDC so these are the the very
well known N1 N2 uh
primers and probes we're not using the
N3 as probably a lot of you may know had
some contamination and false positive
problems
so what you need is two primers to
amplify your Target in a probe that's
specific to that amplicon that you're
that you're detecting and so that probe
is actually what's doing your detection
and so you run this through PCR you get
detection
you get amplification of your target
and that tells you that you have
um
that you have stars Kobe 2 nucleic acid
in the sample
so just to get a little more detail on
that how that process actually detects
um your target
on the left hand side here you can see
just a sort of cartoon diagram of of
What's called the tacman PCR
where we have a forward primer and a
reverse primer that's doing the
amplification of your Target by PCR and
then a probe that has a fluorophore on
it but also a quencher and so the
quencher doesn't allow that fluorophore
to emit any readable signal while it's
intact as you amplify uh your Target and
as that probe has more uh more Target
available to bind to because it's
complementary to the Amplified fragment
um the the amplification enzymes
actually serve to degrade the probe and
so that releases the the fluorophore
from the quencher and so you get
increased fluorescence as you increase
the amount of of probe or the amount of
amplicon you're creating and so you get
a over time over PCR Cycles an increase
in readout and that's diagrammed over on
the right side uh just showing a bunch
of of
cov2 test samples
um with solar fluorescence on the y-axis
um and PCR cycle on the x-axis and so
the blue lines are showing positive
samples where
um as you cycle the PCR you get at some
point you begin at Financial
amplification of your Target and that's
bought out by increasing fluorescence
signal and at some point you cross a
threshold and we call that the CT
threshold and that Crossing that CT
threshold uh
tells us that there is Target there and
we detected it
gives you a positive result and this can
be done quantitatively
um because that CT
the value of that CT actually is
indicative of the viral load of the
sample but it is not used in a
quantitative way in
of covet testing applications because
there are too many other variables like
sample collection
Etc
so it's just a detection or not but it
is somewhat indicative of viral load in
the sample
and
um so just in particular I mentioned
this before but just to show you on on a
on a light spectrum what we're detecting
uh the we're detecting the CDC N1 and 2
targets and we also have an RP Target
which is a human control so that's
that's just telling us that we are
successfully extracting nucleic acid
from the sample and that's a human gene
that we are detecting and N1 and N2 are
our two covet targets and so they
actually live in different the
fluorophoresis that detect those
actually live in different areas of the
of the light spectrum and so what we're
detecting actually are three Targets in
a single well so we're you doing what's
called a multiplex assay
um so we can detect N1 with fam and two
with hex and RP with cy5 those are the
names of the fluorophores we're using to
detect these things and so what we have
is one well per sample in the PCR
but detecting three things
so that's that sort of details of of how
uh PCR based most PCR based Diagnostics
works and so that is how the covet
diagnostic works and the details or the
targets that we're detecting in ours and
a lot of other labs a lot of other uh
developed tests are using those same CBC
uh and one and two primers as well
so many of you may already know what
they are
so just to to set a little bit of a
timeline here
um as I said I wanted to give a little
bit of the origin story
um for how PRL came to be and how the
technology was developed so I mentioned
uh I was in a lab at NYU
um we were developing High throughput uh
DNA assembly technology that we adapted
to to keep PCR based Diagnostics and so
the labs really shut down in early March
or in March of last year for research
and so we we were allowed into the lab
because we were developing uh covet
testing and so
I think early March on the 6th of March
we we sort of sent the first email
Communications around with a group of us
uh sort of coming up with the idea that
we could actually help based on the
technology we had already developed
um we ordered our first uh piece of
extra automation that we needed an ot2
from open trons
um and that arrived only a short uh four
days later we had our first PCR results
um a few days after that
um
and uh and then throughout the spring
and summer there was a whole lot of
optimization development we developed or
we we uh put together what we called
SWAT teams
um that were focused on specific areas
so we had a PCR SWAT team
we had an RNA extraction SWAT team
we got a general automation SWAT team we
even had
a SWAT team dedicated to making PPE for
the community and for hospitals
including 3D printed face Shields Etc
so that was uh all optimization
development validation Etc
um over the spring and summer
um and then we we hooked up with with
open trons at some point in during that
during June we submitted a proposal to
the EDC for to uh to start a Testing Lab
um for the city
um we ended up uh succeeding with that
proposal
um and formed PRL uh and we spent some
time looking for a lab space we did not
take possession of lab space until
August 28th of last year uh and we were
doing live testing two weeks a little
over two weeks later on September 14th
uh which is pretty wild
that was a rough two weeks of lab setup
uh equipment validation work etc
um so we we submitted our eua and our
ldt on the 10th
state
um and we've been testing ever since
we've also submitted an eua an ldt for
pooling pool sampling or pool testing
and for a combined covet and flu test as
well and on the bottom I'm just I just
wanted to show some of the early photos
from that very early work in the lab so
on the far left on the bottom is is the
drawing of our very first PCR
experiments the design of those
um and then on next to that is the is a
diagram which you'll see a little more
fleshed out version a few slides of our
first sort of sample tracking overview
and and all the software involved what
the software would have to keep track of
to keep track of all of the samples and
then in the middle is some reformatting
early reformatting iterations on the ot2
and then our first two
um
Felix's for RNA extraction and then
finally in September we are making the
news in the the lab
so one other
just to get into some of the details of
the pipeline
um one of the other things that uh I
wanted to mention is that we also
inactivate all of our samples because if
you can imagine we're processing 30 000
samples a day we're taking we're
processing about nine ninety thousand
milliliters of of sample every day and
thinking about that much live virus
potentially live kova test was a little
unnerving so we did some experiments
early on looking at inactivation of the
sample just to make sure we couldn't
activate it and still detect virus and
so an hour we or an activation is an
hour at 65c and we uh some data showing
on the right but we also have a lot more
than than what I'm showing here suggests
that we lose about one CT of detection
with that inactivation process
which we uh accepted for the sake of
safety for lab Personnel Etc
so all sort of distilled down a little
bit of a few months of work
um in also in the RNA extraction stuff
uh we custom designed
um our extraction uh protocol we run 94
samples on a run so there's two control
Wells it has about a 35 minute run time
on on the Felix uh which is a 96 volt
liquid Handler we are using an
off-the-shelf reagent set called Meg Max
which a lot of people are using
um though we have been developing a a
Homebrew reagent mix which we haven't
started using yet but it has a very
promising results that actually look uh
to be more efficient and much cheaper
for us
so we are working on things like that
and our limited detection is about 200
to 300 virus per milliliter of Originals
that's
it so just to lay it all out there uh in
uh some detail this is the whole
pipeline as it exists so
um we acquire samples we accession them
and while we're accessing them we we
place them in
um custom sample racks that we had
designed and manufactured for our
reformatting equipment which is
currently an open trons ot2 robot which
maybe some of you are familiar with
um
and then uh that is a single channel uh
transfer of an aliquot from every
specimen
um into a 96 wall plate so that we it's
more amountable to Automation and then
it goes from there everything's done at
96 or 384 Wells at a time and so the
Felix uh does our extraction as I
mentioned
um
we had a lot of In-House experience in
the lab at NYU because we're already
using it for a similar purpose
um and then we put it on then our RNA
samples go on what's called what we call
the work cell which is a light cycler
for the qpcr plus some other ancillary
equipment to help set up that PCR
um we already also had this work cell as
I mentioned for for our qpcr high
throughput qpcr platform at NYU so it's
it's designed uh very much after that
one the one we are using in PRL
in terms of throughput on on each of
these steps
um the accessioning as an estimate we
get 32 samples per rack an estimate is
that it takes about 10 minutes to
accession one rack of tubes so a
well-trained experienced successioner
can do about 180 samples in an hour
um the sample reformatting on the on
each ot2 takes about an hour for per
plate of 94 samples
and then the extraction takes about 40
minutes or so with some setup time uh
per 94 samples and then the light cycler
run we are doing 376 Wells at a time and
so 376 samples per run that takes about
an hour we have two light cyclers on
each work cell so each work cell can do
about 750 samples per hour
and if you look at those throughputs of
each individual step there is some
difference in throughput and so this
isn't really a one-to-one process but
rather a mini to one process so this is
the sort of real Stoichiometry of of the
testing lab as it exists right now and
this is laying out the equipment that's
present on what we call one line which
is just one set of parallelized
equipment
um that is one unit essentially
um that leads to one work cell and so
one work cell as I said has two light
cycles on it we need eight felixes to
feed those two light cyclers and we need
about 12
ot2s to feed those felixes for
extraction and so these are the
stoichiometries that we actually have in
the lab
um we currently have
uh three lines operating and so we have
30 roughly 36 ot2s I think we have a few
extra we have 24 felixes six light
cyclers and so we can do about
uh 2200 samples per hour or
000 samples per day assuming around a 21
hour uptime and we are operating 24 7 so
that 21 hour uptime is pretty accurate
and allows for uh some
downtime
so putting a little more
detail on here because it's not enough
to just take in samples and process them
all through a bunch of robots you
actually do have to
get the result for every test and send
it out to the right person
of course so what we did
um along with all the testing all of the
scientific side and and the extraction
and formatting and PCR Etc is we built
an entire uh in-house made software
layer that tracks the sample through all
of these handoffs through all of the the
processes and the robotics uh and then
also analyzes the results of the PCR and
sends a result to the uh the client
software so that a doctor or a patient
can receive that result properly
um and so we call that system David it
stands for diagnosing viral disease is
also a nod to David Baltimore who many
of you may know is a very well-known
virologist
um
and so David in this diagram as it
exists right now is depicted in this
blue uh horizontal line in the middle of
the slide and
it uh talks to a middleware software
um that actually is what currently talks
to the client software and so the client
software here would be something like
epic or Cerner
Etc
um and David and the middleware talked
to each other at two stages one is the
reformatting scan so we have a scan
before we format all of the tubes into
the into the plate and we have a result
upload at the very end of the test
process
um all in between those two steps uh
everything is is scanned but everything
is sort of processed internally to David
in the lab and so
at accessioning we're really talking to
the middleware software and then David
has to talk to that software to then
verify that the accessioning scan is
this tubes in the racks from the
accession scan are also in the in the
same position for reformatting and then
all of that after that is really an
automated scanning and it's scanned a
plate at a time and so we have to uh
make sure that the reason we have two
scans up front is to make sure that as
we're scanning a plate we know that
every sample in that plate is in the
right slot because we can no longer scan
each individual sample at that point we
have to rely on the single plate barcode
to represent the 94 samples and then
finally the 300g4 samples and the light
cycle website so this is a little
complicated so a huge effort being put
in right now is to really simplify this
um
and make David a little smarter so this
is this is what we're working on now is
to is to sort of get rid of that
middleware layer
um and have David be talking directly to
the client and directly to all of the
automation equipment and all of the
users in the lab and have that really be
a two-way communication as well
um
because in the current iteration David
really just gets presented data from
instruments
um but has no interaction with those
instruments other than that we are
working to integrate David directly with
instrumentation to run it Etc
um and also monitor those instruments
for faults Etc
so this is the sort of dream that's
happening right now
um just to show you guys a taste because
David is also what we use in lab to do
the analysis and releasing the results
um so just to give you guys a small
taste of what that looks like this is a
screenshot of a actual PCR test plate
that came through the lab recently and
so it's showing the 384 plate format of
of the PCR plate
um
we're seeing on the upper left of that
of that uh diagram uh the N1 N2 and RP
tab so you can see the signal in all of
the wells or all of the channels um and
then you can you can also list through
those results and this just gives you a
plate
Centric overview of the results
you can see in the bottom left are our
three controls actually uh so we have
three positive RNA controls at different
concentrations and then a single empty
uh negative control
in the upper left of that that four well
quadrant so this plate looks good
um and then you can also visualize so
actually the diagram I showed earlier
this is exactly the same figure this is
actually taken directly from our
in-house uh analysis software and this
just allows you to sort of make sure all
of these curves have nice nice shapes to
them there's nothing goofy going on in
the PCR that you need to be concerned
about and then um
uh so all of these plates every single
plate we run through the lab is actually
reviewed in this way by a technician and
then released manually to the software
uh into the hospital system
um so I'll give you a little bit of
statistics on on our testing uh numbers
um I've mentioned already we're doing
about we have the capacity to do about
45 000 tests per day
um since September 1st or September 14th
when we turned all the machines on
um we've done about two just over two
and a half million total tests
um so on on the right side is just a
cumulative uh graph of all of our
testing and you can sort of see we
started pretty slow at the beginning as
we're bringing on
um
clients and and have been ramping since
then
um
and
we've also since September 14th have
been running 24 7 we started 24 7 and
we've continued 24 7 with three shifts
um with with over 100 staff on hand
um
as well
um our turnaround time is quite good so
our goal from the beginning has been to
have turnaround time under 24 hours
um we've so far met that goal quite
easily
so half of our samples actually we turn
around in 10 hours or less 95 of them in
18 hours or less and and
almost 100 percent are less than 24
hours
so some of the the current work that
we're working on we're sort of we're not
optimizing right now
um because our work is never really done
uh of course
um we're we're working on Sample
collection
um so right now we are taking a huge
variety of sample types or sample tubes
um just due to the number of clients
we're taking on and there uh in this
just simply that there aren't enough
sample collection devices to go around
and so people are just getting whatever
they can buy essentially and we are able
due to sort of our flexibility and that
our custom racks and all of that and
which we can very quickly design new
ones and have them very quickly
manufactured
um
are able to accept a variety of
different different sample collection
devices
um but that said standardizing that
sample question
um would make our lives easier
everyone's lives easier I think and
there are ways to do this I think in in
much safer and more automation friendly
formats which I'll mention it's a little
bit briefly about in a couple slides
we're also working on alternative
instrumentation
um so one thing we'd like to really do
is is automate accessioning as much as
possible it's currently a 100 manual
process so we'd really like to automate
that a little more so that we can
increase uh throughput and reliability
of that process
some formatting
we would also we're working on different
instrumentation to increase throughput
and decrease our Hands-On time it's
currently a fairly Hands-On process even
though the the liquid handling is all
extraction we're also working on
alternative instrumentation to to
increase through but again and also
decrease Hands-On by by having
a robot load that load the Rope the deck
with reagents Etc
um
and then
um as I mentioned we're also working on
the sample tracking uh pipeline to
really optimize that and turn it into a
much more fleshed out uh system
um including things like live tracking
so that we can query where any given
sample is or just be live aware so this
would be akin to what many of you may
know uh is the Domino's Pizza Tracker
which you used to I don't know if you
still can maybe but you used to be able
to track where your what stage your
pizza was at uh online
um and then of course the instrument
integration and so this turns it into
turns David into a two-way street
basically talking to instruments and
being talked to by instruments
so just to give you an example of of the
first thing the sample collection that
we're working on and uh sort of seeing
fully increased adoption
um
if I if I re-show you the sort of
overall pipeline of the
acquisition accessioning reformatting
isolation and PCR that pipeline really
takes
you know it's about an hour at each step
but
um just to include them processing time
the sort of theoretical minimum here is
about six to seven hours
um
and so we could decrease this if we got
rid of some of these steps uh and sort
of obviated their them and so one of the
things we've been working on is this
sample collection in a
more automation friendly format so
these are sometimes referred to as
Matrix tubes um which is a specific
brand name of these types of tubes but
really they're just uh 96 wall format
tubes that have a 2d barcode integrated
to onto the tube
um and so you can put media in these
tubes and you can collect samples
directly into them and then you really
don't have to do any of the reformatting
steps
um depending on the media you've put in
say DNA RNA Shield which is a product
from zymo which sort of instantly
inactivates the virus but also preserves
the RNA and DNA that's in that sample
then you also don't have to do any
inactivation of that sample and it's
completely safe for the person
collecting the sample for the people
transporting the sample and for the
people in the lab processing the sample
it also eliminates any need for cold
chain it's they're stable for at least
30 days at room temperature
um uh with no loss of detection ability
and then you can also because of the 2D
integrated barcodes you can accession
these things 96 samples at a time or a
full plate you can Decap them 96 at a
time and recap them 96 at a time and you
can put them directly onto the
extraction robot instead of doing this
shades are processing time to about two
to three hours so we are seeing we are
currently collecting with these
um
and seeing increased increased adoption
and it's really driving our turnaround
times down to a well below 10 hours for
a lot of samples
um so some other things that we're
currently working on
um are are pool testing for schools
and here I'm talking some of you uh
probably know of pool testing as uh
lab-based pools so individual samples
would come in and then the lab just to
deal with the volume uh would pool
multiple samples together
and test that
that would reflex
to to sort of distinguish which sample
in a positive pool was positive here we
are capable of doing that although we
have not turned that capability on live
yet
as we haven't really had the need to uh
capacity wise so here though we what
we're ramping up to start very soon in
the next couple weeks is uh what I call
site pool testing
basically you have a number of people at
a specific site
a good example of this is a classroom
you'd have a classroom of 20 20 kids
or so
um each of them does a an anterior nasal
swab puts all of those swabs go into the
same tube and so you have one tube that
represents every kid in the classroom
it's all essentially Anonymous apart
from the identification of the classroom
um those samples get sent to the lab and
we test them as a pool and we can only
report back
and the uh I should Advance this my
apologies so I'm just showing on the top
the the normal test pipeline we see an
individual diagnosis uh for an
individual sample for an individual
person on the bottom what I was just
explaining is this site pool testing
where we have many people putting their
swabs into a single tube we get them in
the lab we hydrate those two those swabs
because they're delivered to us dry and
then we extract and we can say that a
pool was positive
um not that any individual person was
positive and this is just a a
surveillance measure that works well for
cases of low positivity and then in a
positive pool we could reflex back for
individual testing
who who the positive
member of that pool when we're starting
this in the NYC and DC area this month
another thing we're working on uh is at
home saliva collection so in this case
we would have we are working with a
Telehealth partner to
serve as the uh
prescriber of an at-home collection
device uh covet test that uses saliva
and so a person would order the test
they would submit the saliva sample
um by mail to us we would do that test
individually in the lab and report it
back to say an app that our Telehealth
provider has built and so this see we're
ramping this up in the next month or two
it looks like
so what else um in the interest of time
I'm not going to go into too much detail
here but we are opening uh some new Labs
so we're opening DC I think next week uh
LA and Seattle we are also opening new
Labs very soon and then we have six
additional Labs beyond that
um originally planned for for 20 uh by
2022 and so this is a huge amount of
infrastructure for testing for something
that will hopefully be disappearing or
or at least waning very soon in in covid
um and so
but what we think we've built is a
really uh differentiated platform for
low-cost High throughput TCR based
testing
um and that flexibility and low cost and
high throughput means that we can it can
really be adapted to any nearly any uh
PCR based Diagnostic and so that's
exactly what we are trying to do so and
it and that would require really minimal
sample handling changes to the front end
um and so our next products that we're
working on currently in the lab
um
are a respiratory panel we're actually
submitting this within the next week or
two
um for approval uh as an ldt
um this has 18 targets included on it
we're also working on STD panel a GI
panel and blood panel
to be
submitted uh
plan for this year
so that's where TRL testing Diagnostics
is right now so I'm going to quickly
um go through uh the next sort of topic
since we covered the testing and that
sequencing so I showed this exact same
diagram at the beginning of the testing
slides but I wanted to show it again for
the sequencing slides is just to
differentiate what
sequencing is really doing for us so
as I showed this is a diagram of of a
generic coronavirus genome and we're
only testing for the presence of the
engine or the nucleic acid Gene by PCR
and that's sort of on the lowers half of
this exactly the sequences that these
primers are binding to they're very near
each other and so this is really looking
for a very small part of this genome
um which is actually rather large for a
virus and so sequencing what sequencing
tells us is not just that this engine is
present or that these little amplicons
are present but rather that one the
whole thing is present but also exactly
what the sequence of that of that virus
is in a specific sample because as we
know viruses mutate very quickly and as
I'm sure everybody is aware of there are
a lot of concerns about new variants
popping up
that can sort of uh evade the vaccine
the vaccines that are out or evade prior
infection protection
so sequencing is a very important uh
part of surveillance and so we've been
ramping up sequencing very recently
um in the lab to to do that surveillance
um and so one of the very important
aspects of our sequencing pipeline is
that it's integrated directly into the
testing line and so
um what I mean by that is that the RNA
that we isolate for the PCR test
actually is diverted directly well it's
also carried through the PCR it's saved
and diverted directly to the sequencing
pipeline for any positive specimens that
we'd like to sequence
um
and just to put a little more detail on
that
um the the NYC test lab which is on the
east side of Manhattan
um near NYU langone
um
is doing the testing and the isolation
and then we transfer it to our
sequencing facility in Long Island City
where I'm at now
um and and then it goes through a
complicated sample processing pipeline
where we hit pick positive rnas that
pass our criteria for sequencing we do a
library prep on those samples and then
we are able to sequence them
um and with some success rate
um our current sequencing capability in
terms of equipment is uh on the right
side here so we have a my seek we have a
next seek 550 and a next week 2000 uh
which are essentially running all day
every day
uh and just to show a similar timeline
for the development of the sequencing
although it's quite small because it
happened very very quickly our first
pilot test of that pipeline uh were done
in December and
um by February 1st we had agreed to
start sequencing for the city at a rate
of about 500 genomes per week but
ramping to 2000 per week through
February and March and so we've been uh
nearly we haven't uh we didn't quite hit
2000 a week until actually sometime in
April but that's what we were ramping
towards
um and while we were doing that of
course we were simultaneously sort of
developing all of the process involved
in transport transporting RNA and
maintaining Integrity of those samples
during that transport and handling in
the signaling lab which we by the way
did not move into the sequencing lab
until uh early January so it's been a
wild ride
um and we're currently continuing to
ramp that sequencing capacity to a goal
of about 10 000 genomes per week
and just to show some some data here uh
this is a a plot of
sequences in just Aid that are coming
from various facilities I've cut a lot
of them out just to show a few key ones
on that top pink line is Wadsworth the
state Doh lab which has been doing a lot
of sequencing and the below that in Blue
uh you'll see Pro NYC which basically
came on the scene
um if you look way down at the bottom of
that inflection there in in February and
it's been uh
ramping very quickly since then
um
notably this does not include 2000
sequences we just submitted earlier this
week and so probably by next week it'll
look something like this uh hopefully
um
so uh we are continuing to ramp and this
is really going to be a linear uh or
more curve continuing
so
uh just to break that uh or sort of zoom
out a little bit to show the New York as
a whole as it relates to other states
um I can see Texas and California really
got off to early sequencing uh starts
um and
down in January New York really started
ramping in that if you look back at the
prior slide you can see that that's
really driven by
started started with Wadsworth and then
uh is is being now driven by a
combination of us and Wadsworth
um
and to show this and broken down by by
variants
um this is not detected only by Pro
um but these are the Ramp rates of the
appearance of various variants in the
New York New Jersey and Connecticut area
so this data really is from PRL so this
was actually featured in The New York
Times recently uh early this week
um so this is just showing the
appearance or the the ratios of
different variants in our sequencing
results across the last several weeks so
as you can the really appreciate here
the major trend is that variants have
been of concern in color uh are
definitely increasing over time and now
comprise a roughly 80 percent of the
sequences we are seeing and in
particular we're seeing this uh two
dominant variants one is the the b117
commonly referred to as the the UK
variant and then b1526 which actually is
is a New York
origin variant
and
one
uh
other way to show this data is actually
overlaid on the the map of the city
um and so here each plot is just um
uh a week in the last or a couple weeks
in the last uh two months
um and so on the left is is the month of
February where
um
most of the virus or of the genome
sequences we see are actually what we
called other forms or not variants of
concern essentially
um and as you move to the right which is
uh most uh ends on April 1st the very
dominant signal you're seeing is this
pink b1526
um
and that five one two six
um I guess I'll show in a couple slides
it can be broken down a little bit
further
um
so
this is just showing uh some internally
generated plots of the same data up
until April 4th
um of the b117 distribution across the
city
um and then this five to six
which can be broken out as I said into
variants versions without or with this
e484k mutation that is
um
some people worry is is a potential
mutation that can confer the ability to
break through vaccines or or prior
infection protection
and so this is showing the distribution
of samples that have that 484k 526
variants that have that 484k
um
which are distributed across the city
there's a large Spike
spinal Island which is a little
concerning
um and then this is the 5 26 without the
484k mutation
which is distributed quite differently
than than with
um and then the last thing I'll show you
just to wrap it up to combine uh I guess
these two themes of testing and
sequencing is just to show you a plot of
um the test on the left side is our
distribution of of tests and this is the
originating
sample zip code and so
this is a heat map just showing Which
counties or which zip codes uh excuse me
are our tests are coming from and then
on the right is showing which zip codes
are our sequences are coming from
um and the major the major thing I want
to point out here is that we do believe
we are getting a very representative uh
samples of sequences from our test
samples which are really done randomly
with the only criteria being CT value we
typically sequence things of CT values
less than 30 although we randomly will
spike in or throw in some higher ones
just to see what we can do and we do
some sometimes successfully sequence
those
um and that criteria is really just to
increase the probability of success
because High CT samples are very
difficult to sequence
um
so really just wanted to show that that
we are getting a very good broad
distribution of the city in our
sequencing and not biasing it towards
any any one area
um outside of where our sequencing or
our testing is biased so I'll wrap up by
thanking uh the people who make it
happen so this is the executive team
John Vidal the CEO
um Chris Mall formerly of Salesforce
Greg Greeley our CEO of Amazon and
sharag is our medical director CJ who is
really running the strategy and Ops Team
um and then our scientific Advisory
Board uh Jeff Buca at NYU is the the
chair of that
um and then we we have uh six other
members that that are helping uh
guide us uh and then the real people
that actually do the work uh day to day
um so I split this out into the PCR test
development team which is led by Nelly
ostrov
um formerly of Harvard
um and then a team of very very bright
uh scientists and technicians
um and managers and then the sequencing
development team is led by Henry Lee
um and uh Michael hammerling and hyping
who are the the lead scientists and then
another team of very uh awesome
technicians and scientists and then our
project management team who really
helped keep us all in control uh so
thank you very much for listening
and I'll uh I'm happy to answer any
questions
that you guys have
written